not a lot to say and appropriately so
it's just a time of year it is just put
up or shut up time and we didn't get the
job done today we accept responsibility
for that unfortunate Mike Tomlin after
the Pittsburgh Steelers lost to the New
York Jets on Sunday one of us called it
and it wasn't me the Steelers
despite that magical season they were
putting together winning games they
shouldn't have won beating teams like
the Rams teams like the cults they
played the the Ravens incredibly close
back in week four I think that was week
five maybe but the the Steelers just
reality is caught up with them yeah well
it's the answer Mason Rudolph isn't the
answer and they can't get Ben
Roethlisberger back soon enough no
you're you're and then you know it just
it's hard to play that style of football
right Mike I mean just you know it's hey
the defense we know how special it is
it's a special defense but it's hard
just every week to think our defense is
gonna shut them out and cause two or
three turnovers and give us the short
field it's just too hard this day and
age in the NFL that way and they played
a team who's kind of similar to them
they wanted to play defense and they you
know are kind of conservative on the
offensive side of the ball except with
that side of the ball they have Sam
Donald and levy on bail and Robbie
Anderson and they have a few weapons
that can get them over the hump to score
16 points against a great demon swear
you know the Steelers don't have that
guy on offense or the running attack
right now to get them over the hump and
games like this and really if it wasn't
for the end of the half strip sack
fumble and then too bad defense that
caused by Greg Williams
you know the Steelers weren't unable to
really do anything on offense for the
majority of the day yesterday Steelers
now need help to get into the postseason
they must beat the Ravens on Sunday in
Baltimore the Ravens will decide on
Monday whether or not they will be
playing their starters for that game if
you're the Ravens Michael Florio III
would play I would put my starters
through the full week of preparation as
if it was a normal game yeah and I would
play them for half at the most a half at
the most I know is it's a tough one
because I know John Harbaugh
told you so it's tough to like want to
give your guys three weeks off they said
we have to keep getting better you're
you set yourself up for upsets
but three weeks off you do in the
divisional playoff game and I think
we've seen New England you know the last
few years they played their last like
that week 17 game I think for that
reason because they're just going you
know it's just too hard to take three
weeks off and then come out in the
divisional playoff game the biggest game
of the year and think you're gonna hit
the ground running so I'm with you they
got a play for at least a period of time
and prepare like they're really gonna
play because I think it could lead to
bad things in the divisional playoff
game with that much time and when we
have seen that before and that three
weeks is a very very long time so the
Steelers need to beat the Ravens yeah
and the Steelers need the Titans to lose
to the Texans now there's another
scenario for the Steelers it gets a
little complicated but they did that
it's a weird jumble for that last spot
it's gonna be the Titans or the Steelers
the Titans win and it's theirs but if
the Titans lose then this chain of
events potentially unfolds where Titans
lose Steelers lose Colts win Raiders and
Raiders on strength of victory still
have a base they have like 11 things
that have to fall their way and five of
them have already happened well the
other thing too with the Steelers to the
ravens is the Titans are playing the
Texas and I would think the Texans since
they're already locked into the
wild-card spot and a home wild-card game
they could move to number three I could
move to number three I don't know if
it's worth it to me for that and that
scenario I would be a little the Texans
like who cares - so you want the bills
though wouldn't you like to avoid the
bills so I don't know do you want to
play the Titans again - I don't know if
you want to do that either well if you
win though you don't play the type you
win you know if you don't yeah well no
if you win if you right means the Titans
lose you're right the Titans lose and
then you got the Steelers or the braider
right I don't think I want the bills
I think the bills were capable of going
into Houston and beating the 100% I'm
with you there I do I think I think
Buffalo is yeah definitely capable be
Houston I don't know if they have enough
offense to beat Kansas City but but
that's part of the strategic decision
both the Ravens and the Texans have to
make like is it really worth trying to
improve here's the other reason and we
had this conversation a couple of years
ago when there was a debate as to
whether or not the Saints should be the
three seed or the four seed because of
who their wildcard opponent was gonna be
and Tony Dungy made the point always try
to get the higher seed because you still
may end up host 2000 ship game exactly
yeah exactly we're the three seed the
Patriots were the four seed and they
both
ended up in the AFC championship game
the and the Colts got to play home which
was a huge event and there was an
argument to be made that you're better
off being the four seed in the wild-card
round that units like no we want to be
the three seed right because the way
this all plays out we man and make it to
the Super Bowl in win the Super Bowl so
always try to get the higher seat maybe
Bill O'Brien needs to talk to Tony Dungy
before he makes that decision about
whether to lay down or try to go for the
three seed but he still needs the Chiefs
to lose to the Chargers yeah I wouldn't
bet on that one based on the way the
charges been out laying in the Chiefs
have been playing especially on defense
right so it's going to be even though
the Titans lost by ten they didn't play
Derrick Henry and he he was not really a
healthy scratch but kind of at like an
injured scratch like a guy who could
have played if they didn't have a game
that really meant nothing in the grand
scheme of things they still have to beat
the Texans neck next week and I think
they're capable of it yeah especially if
the Texans aren't going all in and then
we see the Titans in the playoffs and
that's another reason for the Texans to
try to win the game you do not want a
team from your division in the playoffs
period you don't want it you don't want
to come across them in the postseason
you just like the Ravens should not want
the Steelers because that's your worst
nightmare if you're the 1 seed and the
Steelers get the 6 seed and they beat
the 3 seed and they roll in and they're
hot and and and they know you and
they're not intimidated by you and I
wouldn't want that if I was the Ravens
that's the nightmare scenario is having
the Steelers as their division round
opponent yeah well yeah I think that you
mean for the ravens you're saying you
don't want that yeah I get you although
I guess the other alternative is the
Chiefs that's the night tonight yeah I
don't know but it wouldn't be the Chiefs
it's the Chiefs of the three there won't
be they'll be in New England yeah yeah
yeah you're right so I mean listen the
Ravens are the best for the Ravens the
best case for the Ravens is to keep the
Chiefs and the Patriots locked in at 2
and 3 so they play each other yeah knock
one out right and then you give me the
Texans fine they already destroyed your
necks right no it's looking like it's
gonna shape up that way without a doubt
you know maybe it ends up being
Tennessee down in Baltimore or whatever
it may be the other game we got a hit on
is that the Saints and Titans a little
bit right I mean to me that was a
fascinating game yesterday just because
the Saints offense came out struggles
ville the Titans came down you know Joe
News Smith catches a ball on the left
side lines breaks a few tackles long
touchdown you know great design little
toss reverse sweep to AJ Brown touchdown
14 nothing you're going whoa
Titans jumping out here not looking good
for the Saints the Saints go down and
get a field goal and it was a lot of
work but then the Saints defense really
just shut down the Titans for you know
the majority of the second quarter and
third quarter and and you know as we
always know Sean Payton Drew Brees and
company kind of found their footing
found out how they wanted to attack a
big pass play by Jared cook kind of
seemed to open up the vault for the the
New Orleans Saints and they kind of
rolled on from a victory there and then
the Titans kind of came back but the
Saints defense answered with the big you
know fumble and fumble return that led
them to their last score to really kind
of put the nail in the coffin
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports